i want to jump into the story about ufos
because i know you're you're an
enthusiast
right right yeah so we have the story
that uh uh it's actually been going
around for a little bit we've talked
about it quite a bit
pictures and videos show unidentified
flying objects moving above u.s
navy warships this story uh was updated
just recently the other day and the
reason it's significant
military u.s naval ships national
security
installations are being spied on
essentially
something is flying above them
surveilling them perhaps
they're they're described as what tic
tacs well they're various forms uh tic
tacs
um triangles um
spheres encased in cubes and you know
all over the place you're saying
yeah yeah all over i mean the ones that
we're looking at that have hit the news
in recent years
i'm sorry spheres encased in cubes yeah
that was the 2015
um uh 2015 theodore roosevelt carrier
strike group one of the pilots described
it looked like a sphere in case nearly
hit him
and so there are various forms that's
crazy yeah and this stuff is not i mean
this is what's
you know i i'm you know i do have a kind
of
eccentric sort of you know british sense
of humor whatever i'm relatively young
as a journalist i i tell people i'm
covering this
issue because i feel my sourcing on it
is very good
um it's complementary to kind of writing
about russian and chinese
military activities research and
development
you know it would be a very bad idea for
me to lean into this subject as i have
if i wasn't very very confident because
credibility wise
you become you know a looney tune
right yeah um so it is happening uh it's
happening near the
navy predominantly uh in their work up
areas off the east and west coast
uh the navy assesses that at least a
significant part of the reason it is
happening near the carriers and the
submarines
is because of the nuclear reactors and
weapons in some cases on those that
these things are attracted to it
that is top secret um because the the us
does not want china and russia
to figure out how that detection
capability comes about wow because if
they
did figure that out they could destroy
our nuclear deterrent forces yeah so
what you're saying that these weird
flying things
somehow can detect our nuclear
capabilities yes yes and we don't want
russia and china to know how to detect
ourselves
and that that's that's you know that's
classified that that assessment but it's
but it's not russia and china doing this
no it's not it's a hype we up you know
tim mcmillan who really i think is
probably the top journalist on this
at least from the u.s point of view in
the world the debrief um both
him and myself um you know
have said you know it's 99 sure we are
not simply because of
um you know as we understand it what
china and russia have in development and
they do have for example on hypersonic
hypersonic glide vehicles which are
going to be the new form of delivering
nuclear weapons um the russians
are at least in delivered platforms that
are deployed
more advanced than the united states
that's going to change soon
um but that's their top end stuff
this stuff is going hypersonic but from
stop to start
no jet fuel no no sonic boom no sonic
boom and some k yeah
no sonic boom in most cases um the
propulsion vectors
uh the behavior patterns so you know the
top lines intelligently controlled
machines because of how they
interact uh happening since the end of
the second world war
and again this is just focusing on
military credible sources not you know
and i think a lot of these witnesses are
probably telling the truth but but you
know you want to go with police officers
people who have a lot to lose by saying
i saw this all radar data platforms
um intelligent control machines capable
trans-medium travel underwater space um
you know through the air and again since
the
end of the second war really and we yeah
we had marco rubio i think recently he
said
that we be like it's it's a serious
threat we should talk about because we
don't know who this is and they're
flying over our nationals
right and he talks about strategic
import he's talking about the nuclear
connection there right
uh and it you know marco ruby also wants
to run president again in the future
he's the chair of the senate and tower
actually now the vice chair of the
center
senate intelligence committee um you
know
he knows he's seen that he knows this is
really a it's not china russia or us
something's going on um i'm going to
keep pushing this subject because it's
going to be good for my political career
and i think he thinks the public should
know more is it aliens i think it
probably is yes
you think it's probably alien i think it
is probably a i am almost
i'm highly confident it is either aliens
or extra dimensional or something
or something crazy oh and i really hey
listen
that's a big thing to say right um you
know it's i
i think that will be borne out uh in our
lifetimes that it's it's it really is
something else
because if you again it's the sherlock
holmes thing right or you know
you eliminate the impossible all you're
left with it is not u.s china russia
or elon musk and it's machinery and it's
intelligently controlled
i don't know if there are people in it
or whatever uh and it's been happening
since the second world war yeah
the manhattan project right you people
like google los alamos
um little green orbs you know
inter-dimensional dude that's oh yeah
you know extra dimension whatever
you know i i don't know and then that is
the sort of generous point that it's
something other
right yeah um but but that's that's the
basic that's why marco rubio is leaning
into this
because they know it's not the russians
and chinese and they don't and they you
know
so there's a conspiracy theory that once
we we actually dropped the nukes
we basically sent a signal right so
those who could attacked
nuclear capabilities were like what are
these these
these you know creatures doing this is
insane high level of intellect
right technical proficiency and they
understand how devastating these weapons
can be and then there's other
conspiracies that they've shut off our
nuclear capabilities in the past
yeah robert hastings uh who's become a
friend of mine he's the guy who wrote
the kind of bible on that ufo is a nuke
not a terribly original title but the
the sourcing is excellent uh and yes
they have and they've done it to the
russians
what's interesting as well is the um you
know the russians and chinese
had these experiences still um you know
nuclear platform sites as
um and uh the russians
uh being russians in the cold winter
tried to shoot these things down
a couple of times and the pilots ended
up die um so
yeah yeah so there's a part i don't know
more than that that was actually came
out in a declassified
british military report i've heard it
from you know at least one other source
very good so there's a lot more to this
subject you ever see
stranger things uh no are you familiar
with the show
right so it's like there's the upside
down right when i when i think about
extra dimensional there's
there's one thing i've often wondered we
have
invisible means of data transmission
right
we use electromagnetic electromagnetic
waves of various uh frequencies
to send signals to other devices and i
often wondered i wonder if what is
invisible to us
is actually a physical phenomenon in
another dimension of sorts that we can't
perceive
and so we are actually just completely
ignorant of what we're doing
maybe on the other side so as we
broadcast a signal
you know like a five gigahertz signal to
us nothing happens we don't see anything
it's not ionizing radiation
but then maybe in this another dimension
or the upside down or whatever
it's actually like ripples like
pushing through water having a very
serious impact on something that might
be on the other side
yeah so real quick just when we talk
about extra dimensional i wonder if then
the reason they're detecting the nuclear
uh reactors and energy is because it's
having a physical reaction
in their dimension or whatever right
maybe you know i mean
we don't know it's a wild wild crazy
thought to be
to be honest i have no idea there is you
know and you can go back in
in time you look at um you know there
was a situation with
one of the you know very top uh roman
generals
um i think finding the thracians uh
where
the testimony um of i forget the the
roman historian
um and it's actually on ufo sightings
you know wikipedia page but i went and
backtracked the sourcing is legitimate
uh describing what looks like ufo coming
in between two armies
um the behavior patterns of some of
these things are really interesting and
where they appear you know there's a
school connection point
um yep school in zimbabwe ariel school
in
1994 zimbabwe all the kids
eight-year-old nine-year-old kids
describing it um
some of them saying they saw a being
melbourne 1967.
there's one in miami why are they
appearing at school sometimes those are
both saucer type
there's a lot to this it's hot it's easy
to go down
the rabbit hole but uh something
very significant is going on i'll tell
you something crazy
um do you know about the o'hare airport
sighting yeah in 2006 yeah
it was 2006 are you sure uh pretty
confident makes sense
i believe so uh i worked at o'hare until
2006
and i had friends who worked there
i worked in the term in the in the
terminal
not even not the terminal the um this
was in the united it was
it was above so where i worked was just
next to united terminal so i worked for
american eagle airlines which is next to
american airlines and so a bunch of the
guys that uh i'd quit
and then this happened i think uh like
maybe like five or six months after
so i had friends who were still there
and they i and when this happened i was
immediately like yo yo what happened
what did you see
and a bunch of them said they saw it
they said that some
object came down through the clouds or
was
was seen floating in the sky for up for
a little for a minute or two and then
shot straight up and punched a hole in
the clouds
and they were told it was a weather
phenomenon yeah now here's where it gets
crazy
one of my friends said they were driving
to work at the time or i i i
they were driving on manheim road which
is just outside of ohio i don't it's
been a long time mind you it's you know
this is what 15 years
they were on manheim road which is one
of the major roads
that goes up just next to o'hare airport
and they said
when this thing came down people stopped
their cars
and got out and were staring up at it
and i was told that people were taking
pictures
early camera phones existed at the time
and so i was like
where's all that all those photos at now
there was one photo that got released
the pilot was in the plane and he
turned and took and this is grainy you
know crappy photo
but from what i heard and maybe it's
just exaggerations and hear saying it
was wrong
i had someone tell me straight up they
saw people taking pictures of it right
where'd those pictures go
no i didn't we didn't have the internet
we didn't have facebook the way we do so
maybe it's just sitting on these old
you know flip phones from 2006 that
never got put online i've heard the same
thing
um interesting that the descriptions
there were a saucer you know it tends to
be now tic tacs triangles whether that's
multiple or
originating vectors right multiple um
things
but it's a very good point i i also
think though people ask why do we not
have more photos now right with iphones
such good quality you know whatever
phone you have i think that
is going to be these things when they're
seen are either willing to be seen or
want to be seen
they are there are photos of them but
there aren't as many as we might expect
i i think the issue is let me put this
away
i once looked up at the sky and the moon
looked amazing
and i was just looking at the corona and
the color it was like a it was like a
blood moon
with this massive corona and it was a
full moon and i was like
wow let me take a picture of this i put
my camera at it and it's a white dot on
the screen and i'm like i cannot capture
this moment on a phone
right i have seen weird things in the
sky before
that look like there's a tail coming off
and i'm like was that a comment or a
meteorite and i put my camera at it
and you lose all the definition and all
it is is a red dot with a with a grainy
blue background and i'm like damn i
can't take a picture of this
i think people overestimate the power of
cell phone cameras with
long range uh low resolution photographs
right so if you if i guess people are
expecting like the saucer to land in
their backyard and then they get a
higher resolution photo they're not
doing that they've never done that
so one thing though that hopefully you
obviously mentioned jeremy corbell's uh
the photos there were some other ones
that that i had that um
you know uh happened similar well
actually
you know slightly different time um one
thing that
myself and tim mcmillan reported on last
december uh
is a in december 2019 or they're about
um now that the pilots in the f-18s
right from the carrier groups have their
iphones
um they took one aircrew took a photo of
a triangle
uh which we've seen david marlar's
coming out the water
right um and that photo
i have not seen it i know it exists um
you know multiple sources uh and it's
when that photo comes out i think that
will be a really pretty pivotal moment
because it will be from uh
air crew there'll be like chain of
custody uh
and you know when you see that thing and
then when they match up the sensor data
with anyway
these jeremy corbell photos the ones
we're talking about the naval warships
they're they're white they're white
specks yeah i mean you see one of them
looks like a pyramid i mean the navy
were tracking them though
and they did identify them as unknown it
was talked about multiple days
moldable ships and the navy really has
an incentive to to
not want to talk about this stuff susan
goff who leads the press effort at the
pentagon everything goes through her i
reached out to her today
about actually kind of jeremy corbell
stuff
through ncis goes back to her very
tightly controlled
i don't think it's so much that they're
trying to conceal alien bodies in the
basement i think they really don't
they don't know how to handle the issue
and it keeps happening and it's
escalating
so this this is not going away and again
journalistically i think it will do a
lot of favors for my career that i've
lent into it
you said uh it's 99 likely that it's not
uh russian chinese or american where'd
you get that number that that's my
that's my
assessment but i think it's uh i'm very
confident that is
the assessment shared by oni uh office
of naval intelligence which leads the
investigative effort i i
personally i feel like it's more likely
that the navy's lying
than that extraterrestrials are arrived
just
mathematically if likelihood yes i think
you have to
yeah you have to trust um again
your sources you have to look at delib
platforms that are in place and we're
not just
that the thing that's interesting about
these and again looking at
the historic certainly with the
triangles um
the way these things behave non-jet
propulsion
transmedium travel hypersonic
instantaneous acceleration which would
rip a human body apart
unless you have some kind of inertial
developments exactly
space time bubble potentially yeah which
might might be that
might be the things on the side of the
triangle maybe not uh but i think
probably is
um and again that's not me saying that
um
the starboard nacelles
the capabilities across the board
multiple
points right that that you know
hypersonic non-jet propulsion trans
medium
that stuff is so far we don't have any
of that well you could think it could be
plasma like a cloud of plasma being
yeah but then we have we have debris
surface imaging
we have debris metallic debris imagine
so it could be a meta material yeah
imagine someone in the 1800s trying to
explain a jet engine
and they'd be trying to use their
understanding of science
to explain futuristic technology they
wouldn't be thinking about
com these combustion engines in the same
way or more importantly
when we talk about electricity and then
you go back and try to explain it to
someone
in the pre you know pre-electricity
they're not going to understand the
concept of how this works and so they're
going to try and use
their perspective on science you end up
with ideas like the ether you know what
i mean
they don't quite they can't pers they
can't conceptualize this stuff what
debris did they find
uh so the debris in terms of uh
metamaterial
i don't know the i know the us
government has it i've heard that
from uh two extremely good sources
extremely good verified you know
um that it is um
from a crash location you know
identified something went down
recovered and the material analysis of
it there's a lot of different
elements of metamaterial that people say
are from ufos or uaps
and the the us government stuff there's
again chain of custody from siding crash
whatever um that because of
the metallurgy or the the binding of the
metals within it
uh it would be impossible to do with our
understanding of
um manufacturing uh and that it would
require is
you know one very good source told me uh
again
and these are government people right
this is not some you know this is not
researchers who i think there are some
great researches but i'm trying to be
very careful here about being able to
have a governmental link to what i'm
saying
um that that you could not produce it
where you're not in a zero
g zero gravity environment so space
um and so this is something that you
know other people have talked about with
that they say
you know metal analysis um but
you know again when you when you've got
um
the radar returns the icbm satellites
that we in case china just decides to
nuke us in the middle of the night that
we can track it
you've got this stuff coming into orbit
you know you've got it the nuclear
attack submarines catching it underwater
at hundreds of knots
got it in the air you've got the pilot
seeing it
you've got infrared you have
you know just a gamut of sensor data
matched up
at least in limited circumstances to you
know
metallurgical analysis um
you know this this is really something
going on here and again it it's better
actually though to
say right to who the hell is tom rogan
you know the the marco rubio the the
people are leaning into this
um you know it's it's it's something is
going on
yeah and and that's and you know time
will tell i mean i do that metallurgical
analysis right that that is very hard to
as someone told me avoid the physics
just just just kind of
you know uh focus on it's really
interesting and and
here's what we know it's a div but it's
the seal has been broken now though
right
and and so it's gonna seem like there
are no physics when it comes to the
metal like i have no
evidence of metallurgy for you to
to see yeah right and the government is
known lying to us like weapons of mass
destruction
yeah well i mean i i don't
intelligence failure um you know
could explain some of this but but again
when you have the cross-section
i i appreciate i spot well i do
appreciate the fact that it's you know
i'm saying right there's what's
this my reporting um but you know i
could be
a liar uh and i could be being misled
he's trying to sell a book i think bob
lazar was misleading no i'm not writing
but yeah i just talked about zeta
reticuli
i don't believe bob i actually
personally don't believe him i think
he's yeah i don't believe him i think he
saw the craft that they were working on
the drones
but then they told him he said they were
a little green man yeah they
they probably they might have no i was a
puppy that guy had attracted
you've got to be you know you've got to
talk to people who who
have the credentials and that's what
i've tried to focus on um
like what what lazar it seems like he
was working on a drone program
and that they told him it was aliens to
throw so that he didn't go and spew like
the government's working on drones i
i zeta reticuli it's nonsense
he went and that now he looks like he's
crazy right doesn't mean that they
weren't working on a drum program i mean
they rated tesla's laboratory in the 20s
i just think he that that guy lacks
credibility yeah i did work his story he
did work sure
sure that's fine but his story's changed
and i'm not interested in someone
said telling a story and being all
smiling confident about then coming out
you know 23 years later
like oh actually that wasn't true
because back then it was sensational got
him on tv
today no one believes it so he takes
that part out of his story he said he
saw a little green man
yeah and i took that out i i was a
puppet
shut up i would say as well there i mean
i
hope
i think my reporting will stand uh on
the merits but i would say
a basic place to start robert hastings
ufos nukes
and david mahler triangle ufos those are
two
very good serious people who are just
keeping it to
eyewitnesses who have credibility and
doing their due diligence
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you